un grand champ de blé est là un passager
inerte de malaisie airlines encore
attaché à son siège
parmi les premiers arrivés sur les lieux
le photojournaliste jérôme sessini
évidemment la première réaction c'était
le froid la peur même quelque chose
d'assez puissant 2
j'ai ressenti de la peur en voyant cette
peur de quoi en fait je sais diffus je
pourrais pas décrire exactement c'est
son métier il prend des photos
la difficulté pour moi c'était de
trouver la bonne distance pour donner à
mes photos je voulais témoigner décrire
ce qui se passait mais sans donner trop
de
de détails
on dira qu'ils rendraient les photos pas
part aux gardes a bien fait
celle là c'est vraiment la plus
polémique alors cette photo polémique
parce que là j'ai reçu beaucoup
d'insultés photo une photo qui montre le
corps d'un passage est tombé du ciel qui
s'est retrouvé dans une chambre à
coucher
pourquoi vous vous tenez à ce que cette
pub c'est plutôt là soient publiés c'est
le summum de l'horreur c'est l'horreur
pour les victimes du vol c'est l'horreur
pour les personnes village parce que
j'ai rencontré les personnes village
elles sont traumatisés à vie c'est
journal et pour toutes ces photos prises
ailleurs dans le monde des enfants qui
meurent sous les bombes israéliennes sur
une plage à gaza des adultes qui meurent
du virus ebola en afrique
toujours la même question publié ou
censurer ce qu'il faut pas le montrer
non je ne crois pas pourquoi ne pas le
montrer et faire si on commence à se
censurer
ça devient très dangereux
le pass censuré s'est aussi montré un
couple gay partageant un moment
d'intimité en russie cette photo d'un
danois a remporté le premier prix du
world press photo ici maxence bilodeau
radio canada montréal